have a preconceived notion of what I am
capable of just at first sight when I do
my thing and they see it and they're
like whoa I love giving that shock and
awe
feeling it's just like so you think I
can only do this but I'm going to show
you I can do so much more my name is
Dexter maple and I am a plus-sized male
model and professional dancer for about
eight years now oh my goodness the
journey has been long it has been hard
being a bigger person there's not as
many opportunities but at the same time
there's so many opportunities that you
would never expect I'm so happy so I've
been able to dance for Jennifer Lopez
for her poppy music video Sara Bareilles
for her brave music video I was actually
able to walk the runway as a plus-size
model for Marco Marco at LA Fashion Week
and that has been an eye-opening
experience for me I was never actually
trained professionally as a dancer I
never expected to be a professional
dancer given my body type being a gay
black man in America is not easy
especially being a big gay black man in
America and it took me a while to really
find that love for myself my true self
whenever we think of bigger men we view
them as something to laugh at and we're
not that we love our bodies as well and
we are sexy too like I can't say that
enough like we are sexy too at the end
of the day I just want to be seen as
someone who deserves this is someone who
is capable not seen as just an
overweight person not just
as a black actor a dancer not seen as
whatever that first impression is I just
want to be seen as someone who is
talented enough for this job
I was called names such as monster to
face and Scarface hey guys welcome back
to my channel posting my videos made me
realize that this is my mission I
wouldn't take it back this is absolutely
the reason why it happened to me
hey guys welcome back to my channel if
you're new my name is Sheila black today
we are going to be doing makeup blogging
with Shalom and I make youtube videos I
teach people how to do makeup and also
encourage them to love himself for who
they are without the makeup I was burned
by cooking oil
when I was 9 years old and my mother's
restaurant back in Nigeria I remember
waking up to screaming and pulling off
my skin and rubbing off my face it was
really terrible for me
I thought of suicide I was in the mural
just looking at myself like why don't
people just like me
I know that my mom loved me and she
would be really on sad to lose a child
you know because she felt like she lost
one
this is where pretty I started to feel
better about myself when I saw other
people that were burnt too and I wanted
to help people like me
my solution was trying to cover up my
scar so I thought why not
oh makeup this is going to be a talk
through step by step how I cover up the
scar in my face when I get comments for
my view is telling me that I hope them
it makes me remember why I'm doing this
I like to focus positivity on my videos
you know not just putting on the makeup
but having a message that comes with it
that makeup isn't just what I love to do
you know I want to make you feel good
even when you don't have the makeup on
I'm just happy because I found myself I
learned to accept my scars and I also
just love me for who I am
you
I was always big my story was that I was
fat and I was sort of doomed to be fat
and unhappy and and not live the life
that I wanted to live so being able to
break down that story it's been a
lifelong process for me and that's what
I really am aiming to share with other
people is that that story doesn't have
to be true i'm dana fall study and i am
a yoga teacher Yoga is for everyone why
do people need to be skinny to do yoga
this is it's just it doesn't make sense
to me it's the only thing that you need
to practice yoga is the willingness to
try welcome so even bigger breath on
this inhale so belly rises up towards
the sky Rock the hips from side to side
just anything that feels good I travel
all over the world teaching
body-positive workshops so I don't
necessarily teach in a way that is about
modifying or making the practice easier
for anybody based on age or size or
anything like that it's more about
teaching in a way that makes everyone
feel really included and really
comfortable and lift the left arm up I
don't care what it looks like I don't
care what any of you look like just do
it and just feel amazing
from like age 10 or so on
I was always big three years ago started
going to the gym and just being really
active in the pursuit to get smaller and
I lost almost a hundred pounds I got to
my new body and everything was exactly
the same
I wasn't happier and I didn't feel any
better and so I was at this point where
I felt really just kind of lost and
confused about what I needed and so I
went to yoga
before I practiced I didn't realize how
capable my body was because I just felt
like it was fat and like I was lazy and
I believed everything about my body that
sort of society sees when they see a fat
person
I love my body which is crazy because I
really spent my whole life hating it I
mean looking in the mirror and just
feeling so disgusting and I'm proud of
it now and I'm proud to take care of it
you
you get skinny and then you want to
cover it up I just wore clothing baggy
clothes things that hid my body I would
have little games in my head that I
would play like let's see how long I can
go without eating I would definitely
still be starving myself if I had not
gone circus arts I'm Kayla dykes and I'm
a professional aerialist
and a survivor of anorexia I did
gymnastics and developed anorexia and my
pains into my 20s at my lowest point I
was 90 pounds and that's when I
discovered circus arts it changed my
life
because I knew that if I wanted to do it
I needed to grow stronger and grow from
it
it took me eight years to get from there
to here anorexia never really goes away
you just learn how to shut it out when I
look in the mirror now I don't see the
muscle mass I feel small
almost immediately I'm thinking you know
that's not true
you can climb 200 feet straight up I had
no idea from my first day that this
would end up being my profession back
then you know I would cook a pot of
noodles and I would have to get my
then-husband to strain the noodles for
me because I didn't have the strength to
lift the pot of water noodles and pour
it out and I remember asking what is
wrong with me and one of my trainers
looked at me and she said you didn't get
eight I had fallen in love with Ariel so
much so that I was willing to put food
in my mouth and grow some muscle so I
can get up in the air and keep up with
all my classmates
if I could say anything to my inner XXL
it would be that you could be so much
nicer to your body at the time I thought
it was taking care of it I wasn't and I
didn't know any better
I'm capable of so much more
I told myself going into the locker room
Melanie when you had breasts you would
not have been modest you would not be
covering yourself up to any greater
degree so this is what you will do now
when the doctor told me I'm sorry to say
you have breast cancer I just went blank
I was diagnosed needing a single
mastectomy of my right breast I knew
from the start that I wasn't interested
in reconstruction symmetry is important
to me as an individual it's my breasts
or nothing
shopping for that bathing suit that was
hard you know I have 17 inches of scar
on my chest my skin doesn't move the way
it used to and it needs stretching doing
it in the water just feels better than
anything else anywhere else when I made
this decision I told myself just embrace
this
be it be all of it I've posed for a few
different projects the grace project
I've posed for play out underwear these
projects they're great for me there's an
aspect of being able to see myself
I'm not defined by my breasts or my lack
of breasts visual representation for
this body type is very important
so that no woman feel like they need to
hi